but yeah I mean I don't know I I just
I'm I'm a kind of anti-terrorism pro
love same I think most right yeah we all
are dude I went out I went out it's so
comedy is so funny because like you know
it's nothing's funnier I think to other
comics when like a comic bombs so I go
out there last night and yesterday you
know this it is November 14th but last
night was October 13th it's just crazy
the way time works but but last night
was October 13th which Hamas had
announced was World Jihad day wow they
they announced yesterday was a big world
Jihad so I went out there and I said
guys listen first thing you know so
whatever it is four 500 people I said
listen I said I know today's world Jihad
day but let's make it instead of a Jihad
let's have a jaha
bombed laugh bombed and then I said I'm
sorry I'm acting like a
homosexual and and it was crickets
all I heard was my guy who works with me
my friend Don deeta [__] falling over
on the couch in the green room and and
that is enough for me I didn't care I
was like at least the comic left was he
eating Hamas and P
yes yeah dude and [__] it but that
that's you know and then people like oh
that was too soon I'm like shut up no
it's not where was this bre shame on the
people of Brea yes and and and I and I
say that with a heavy heart because Brea
has been very good to me what a great
Club it's a big room there's a saying if
if you build it they will come and they
did this remodel on that club that is
just out of this world yeah I love that
if I love Bria I love and you're doing
nothing with that bitching ass LED wall
behind you nothing they ain't doing [__]
no I'm yeah I'm not I got to get more
multimedia right you're good you're good
at that stuff you're good at making it a
show sometimes with me I'm like what are
these people paying to see me talking
about stupid [__] I wrote in my notebook
I got to make this a show man you put on
a show man you're payt your dick how
long will it take you to do a special
from this material um this is this
material that I'm working on I put on my
last special Espy wesy um last year or
18 months ago and now I'm ready to go
with a new special um like within the
next two to three months I'll tap it
yeah wow that's that's a fast turn well
because because what I try to do is um
when I'm have a special in the can when
spey wesy was shot I'd already had 20
minutes of the new one you're always
going to be a little bit ahead so I try
to do that so I got material now for the
next one stuff that I'm talking about uh
specific stuff with my daughter's
getting older that I'm I hold back I do
it like in the local comedy clubs of New
York but I won't do it on the headlining
set do you already have a name for it
for this special I think I'm going to
call it special little boy this special
maybe or because my last one my daughter
named spey wesy so I don't know I don't
know for me the name I don't I've never
been um so concerned with the name or
what the stage looks like I was like oh
it was always just about the jokes now I
think you have to be more concerned with
the name and the algorithm and this but
I used to like when I would watch like
Bill bur Lou CK those are my two
favorite Comics I never I don't even
know what the names of their specials
are I just know the material and and
that's you know like go their newest one
or the last one yeah I I'm like I know I
know the bits I don't know but again
some people do some people that's what
they're all about like music and I just
never knew any I I don't know what the
hell I was doing when I was a kid or a
teenager I don't maybe in my own world
but I never got I was like I don't want
to take time thinking of this name so
with the Netflix special they were like
coming up with all these different names
and I was like uh I don't know and then
the very last day when I had to name it
I literally asked my daughter she was
six at the time I was like what should I
name my special and she was like she had
Nutella like all over her hands and face
she was like spy wesy I was like that's
it I mean it's very on brand for you
yes that's that's what it you know that
that's so I think I'll either call this
one special little boy or I'll just
maybe I'll ask my 2-year-old my
2-year-old will be three I'll ask I'll
ask car I'll ask her what to name and
I'll let the little one name this
one in in the spey wesy you uh had
a a joke about about somebody in Idaho
watching you said but if you're an Idaho
then like and subscribe and that kind of
threw me a curveball because I thought
hm was this uh taped for Netflix or was
it licensed after the fact like did you
expect that you were going to put it on
YouTube no no as a matter of fact day
when I filmed it nobody wanted uh you
know everybody was passing on me so I
said you know what let's just film it we
did it in the grammar seat theater in
New York Hometown I was like I'll get
you know my people there whatever I said
let's film it and I'm going to put it on
YouTube and I don't care and then at the
end of the special I said I'm putting
this thing on YouTube unless Netflix
wants it then I'll sell it to you right
I said that and in the middle in the
show I had multiple bits just like
[__] on Netflix and cuz I got fired
from a show on Netflix for a joke so I
was like just going to whatever I this
is going on YouTube and then my agent
sent it to Netflix like you know the
next week and they turn around they're
like we want to buy it and I was like oh
sweet but they were like you know we
have notes and I and I told you know my
age tell them I was like there's no
notes either they put it on exactly as I
did it or I'll just put it on YouTube
like I it's it's it's it the whole thing
was for YouTube so I'll put it on I
don't want any notes and they were like
um well you have to at least take the
stuff out about [__] on Netflix and
I said then I'm just going to put it on
YouTube i' like zero I will take out
zero just because I'd appreciative of
Netflix I'd be but I was like this whole
thing is you know my own fans for my
fans I only my career only started to
get going I started doing podcasts and
and that stuff I was like I don't the
networks never gave me anything I lost
stuff from them so I was like I was like
I don't care and they were like but
respectfully like not like I was like I
respectfully don't care I will not take
a note from you um and then they just
like all right fine well we'll put it on
as is then that's great very wildly
different experience than I've had with
Netflix right what are why they I don't
like you know they they did say that my
bucket list special had just too much
dick in it and and
there and there's like there is the the
Seaman flying around yeah they're like
you know what we can't have sto's dick
on but we can put on the dictators
Playbook to teach people how to become
dictators the secrets of you know Kim
jnun and Osama bin lad that's good but
not sto's painted [__] and and I know
man like I I I had a lot of like
self-consciousness around like you know
how people viewed me getting into
standup when I'm the jackass guy and
like that uh [__] kind of you know
bothered me for a long time it doesn't
bother me anymore you know it does it
doesn't bother me anymore like I'm
authentic in what I do I'm un
Unapologetic I don't give a [__] I go
out there and I do my thing and and uh
you know I'm good at it and you've been
doing it now for what 13 years exactly
so you got your 10,000 10 years 10,000
hours in yeah and and so um everybody
can suck my dick but the problem is that
that I think that Netflix and largely
the [__] you know people who put out
comedy specials they just still don't
they're not they're not opening up their
arms to embrace steo comedy welcome let
them suck your paint fil dick do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude